season six yeah this is a wild ride
when you look at kind of the five that
came before it and then this one where
does this stack up for you oh my
goodness most the time when it feels the
hardest it means it made for the best
television so you guys are gonna love it
um but yes I do think that when we're
stacking it I I personally think this is
probably our best season
I'm gonna say it is too okay see I'm not
even just saying that like that fuse
boom
[Music]
two newbies this year yeah we'll start
with brie great
love it were you surprised at the
conversation that happened around her
especially Chelsea's involvement in the
conversation oh my gosh it makes me so
uncomfortable because I genuinely love
these girls so much Chelsea's been super
supportive of me and my untraditional
situation I think that Brie and Chelsea
kind of uh started things off on the
wrong foot and that didn't help let's to
say the least yeah it seems there were
conversations happening and not with
each other that needed to happen correct
the other newbie who I think you're
going to be less excited to talk about
Nicole we see you activated like never
before this season because of Nicole one
thing I have a problem with is a victim
mentality and it's not all about you I
need a gym mentality yes I will I've
been through so much
and you've been wow yeah okay why did
she push you to that place
I think at this point
having gone through all I've been
through with you know the oppenheim
group and filming selling sunset
I think I had expected
a little bit of respect with someone
coming new into the group and she had
reached out and we were great friends
before this and I thought I was excited
for her she asked for advice and I was
trying to help her so the fact that she
had been plotting a plan and I didn't
know it until here she was with the full
camera crew around me obviously that
just set the tone because I don't like
feeling like you've been plotting
something and it's something from so
long ago you could have easily brought
this up a million times before so I just
had very little patience from the
beginning so there are things that I
would have put up in the past because I
just wanted everything to be copacetic
but now I feel like like I said I've
been here too long and I'm too tired I
I'm not the one if you want your you
know TV moment go somewhere else because
I'm not going to be an easy target
anymore yeah that uh brings us to an
Instagram post you made around the time
of filming yes I'm going to read the
full verbatim of what you've posted the
thirst for camera time on season six is
real wow that was insanity but also so
transparent get your 15 minutes girl but
leave my business out of it clown Emoji
of course you have a huge issue with me
now not before when you have a camera
crew around you
some side eye faces it looks like I hate
fake poop emoji if you want camera time
just say that I would have helped you
get the right angle shrug we only saw a
part of that argument yes so is anything
missing that the viewers need to know
about well actually you know because
they don't like to break the fourth wall
a lot of my frustration is that you know
if I you know when you got cast on the
show and you're asking me for advice and
I'm saying I'm so excited for you you
know all these things and then all of a
sudden you're bringing up something from
three years ago
um that to me is extremely frustrating
especially like I said leave my business
out of it is you know calling me a fake
agent trying to tear down my business
things I've worked really hard for I'm
the only girl in the office that has
given her business and that has given
her referrals and so it just really felt
like a betrayal and a clown emoji she
sets this up by saying she's a little
frustrated that you got credit on the
MLS for sales that she completed correct
when you and Mary sit down with her to
finally hash this out she says well I
should have never said that to begin
with so did you ever learn what her
actual issue was or did she present an
actual issue other than that
yeah because she's also on the listing
and both of us were added first of all
so it's ridiculous if you're added okay
I digress
um but yes you're right she says that
wasn't her initial issue and then she
came out with her issue saying that
Jason only put me on the listing because
he had a crush on me which again isn't
much of a point when he's adding you to
way more listings than me and you guys
also did it so I never got to the root
of what her real problem was she kept
bringing up you know how you know I I
didn't let him answer phone calls when
we were together which they cut this out
but I I said that to Jason in front of
everyone have I ever done that and he
said no that's ridiculous so
to me I think it's very clear there
wasn't a point she came in with the plan
she thought she had this you know idea
to kind of come at me and I think that I
surprised her because I just you know
I'm in a different place and I wasn't
having it and I was not an easy opponent
do I you know do I think that I could
have you know done anything differently
yes
but you know when you when you keep
bringing it it's almost like you know
don't keep poking me and then not expect
me to react right so safe to say what
you put in those Instagram stories still
kind of rings true today a hundred
thousand percent then there's the Palm
Springs weekend
the drug test uh full panel drug test
uh why why would you do that those are
very severe and extremely damaging
accusations even though there are many
thousand percent false let me validate
this piece of paper one when you heard
about the drug test what did you think
and two did she ever actually provide
the results of it I have not seen them
but again I think that this was
something that it could have been
something
um
I I think that that kind of made it a
bigger deal uh by contacting an attorney
and all of those things so
um when you really now are at someone's
throat then it almost like is going to
just hype everything up
um
to me it's girl you do what you want to
do I actually don't care I'm not
policing anything my point is just stop
coming for my business what is the issue
why are you so like a rabid dog with a
bone so is it that is it you know is it
camera time is it you know whatever of
course when I if I say camera time
they're not going to use that right we
can use it here on E.T
this only snowballs into season seven
so
is it
today in this moment are you better or
worse off with her so
um no we are not friends
um I think that you know so many things
have happened at this point I'm fine
with that but obviously like I said it
would be nice at this point to just kind
of be not
trying to tear down each other's
business I'm here to say she's great at
what she does I'm never trying to tear
her business down
um but our personalities Clash so I'd
like if we can keep it to that I think
that's actually a great place if we can
get there all right I think before we
can get there we're going to see a lot
more that that is true I say that right
after I just uh well you know what this
is see this is what happens then we have
to answer the question this is the
machine that keeps it going it's just
going in you can say it won't bleep it
murder I say one thing and I'm burned to
the state court you've said terrific
things about me everything I say about
you is hold on I need to pause right or
I'm gonna end you in the sneak peek we
get at the end of season six we hear her
say that you get away with murder
and then she threatens to end you yes
yes so what can you tell me about kind
of those moments I think it's funny that
she thinks I think she can very clearly
she came in with an agenda and now that
it didn't work she's twisting it around
as if she's the victim and I've been out
to get hurt when really the whole time
I'm like please go away what what is
your point I kept trying to get to it
and I never found one so
it's kind of it's an old Playbook I've
seen it before I've dealt with it before
you're coming at me that didn't work and
now all of a sudden you're the victim
that you know is going to act like
you're getting bullied it's it's
literally happened before right which is
why I think we're seeing and you handle
it differently this time because
you've seen this movie Before You Know
How It Ends Christine
Christine
I'm leaving don't do this again to me
you know if you're going to try and
um do something that's already been done
on the show then you have to try and do
it better you can't you know
listen Christine and I have our issues
but the one thing I'll always give her
you know she really sold it on different
aspects and I feel like you know you
can't come in with an old Playbook and
and it's a little right the sequel's got
to be better than the original there you
go
between the Fallout with Nicole figuring
out your new normal post Jason breakup
Mary often chose the side that wasn't
yours or tried to stay neutral
where do you two find yourselves now is
there
a friendship there and how different is
it from what it used to be I love this
question because that's the one thing
that is important to me to clear up is
that there's absolutely a friendship
there there will always be a friendship
there I love Mary and
um you know I don't even feel like she
took a side that wasn't mine I really do
feel like you know she really is that
friend that wants to stay neutral and of
course when you're going through
something it feels a certain way but I
that is how life goes and I think that
um you know
we have a friendship where no matter how
much time does pass the second we talk
and connect it's it's like no time has
passed and so
um I love Mary I'm so happy for her with
everything she has going on and I you
know I feel like with the show we had to
kind of conversations that would have
maybe had quicker they want us to wait
and so it does feel good to finally be
able to get to a place where you know
um they wanted to have that in real time
but now you know that we are done
filming to really work on just getting
our friendship exactly back where it was
and it and it is which I'm really
excited about